from the director who brought you such
classics as Red Sonja and dr. Doolittle
comes his most epic of unimpressive
liebe land masterpieces : doctors trial
in such balls let's watch it
between the years when the ocean last so
we start off with Conan as he's
apparently replaced some Atty with a
very obnoxious comedy relief I think we
made the merchants angry but we didn't
steal everything he had
they got me because Rob Schneider was
off making worse movies I hate it but
there's suddenly surrounded by a ton of
soldiers who attack him with nuts and
sticks hey I don't think it's gonna work
guys
please get in our dad's will be your
friend you know who I am Queen Tara miss
what do you want I need your help that's
why I sent my men to attack you I'm just
saying hello you have nothing you don't
want look at the shrine
show me the desire in your deepest heart
area malaria
her name was malaria all this time
actually it's valaria and if Conan goes
with the Queen she can help bring her
back to life so of course he agrees oh
look he even comes across another camel
like in the first film I'm sorry about
what happened last time
mm-hm yeah how do I get the feeling that
the name of the next film is gonna be
tone and the camel puncher we will drink
two daggers the Dreaming God the God of
nonchalant Ness sorry there's a lot of
story they get out here so listen
closely it is written in the scrolls of
Skelos that a woman child born with a
certain mark must make a perilous
journey it is her destiny sounds like a
pretty stupid destiny my niece Jenna has
such a mark there is a key she must find
a key only she can touch where is it in
a castle guarded by a wizard what is
this key unlock a jeweled home only she
can procure it so you want me to fulfill
the unknown destiny of a scroll I never
read by going to a castle I can't find
to lead a girl I never met to go up
against a magic I cannot fathom and find
a treasure I never heard of yep okay so
before they head out on their quest the
Queen gives her captain of the guards
some specific orders what I do need you
for see that this dear child is returned
safely to the palace the treasure and
her virginity intact
I can definitely protect one of those
but she must be a virgin when she's
returned to me so she can be properly
sacrificed yes make sure absolutely
nothing happens to her so I can kill her
speaking of which how come gods always
want virgins
what sluts be more accepted they put out
more and they just have a better
understanding of the human body is
pleasurably logical but I digress they
set out on their quest and go through
several villages to get to the castle on
the way they come across Mako from the
last movie and made a hey I didn't know
she was in this movie that kicks ass and
ironically the situation suggests she's
in view to a kill save her
thieves should be hanging sue how she
has a forced tail on her ass is that
just the style then look at that a foo
it's not every day you see a horse with
two rear end so maybe wants to join them
for saving her life
the captain tries to shoo her away but
it doesn't seem to work these looks
arousing I'd better join them I swear
that if Conan will let me ride with him
I will give my life for him
we shall see so she joins their team as
they ride to the castle they were
looking for um water it's not usually
the most stable spot to build a castle I
mean seriously who does their castle in
the middle of a swamp
well the Kings thought it was death to
build a castle on this one but I'll
build it all the same just to show him
they sank into the swamp we then cut to
the wizard who owns the castle hey is
the Burger Kings mutilated brother
Daniel so they decide to rest for the
night while the evil wizard transforms
himself into a hideous beast butterfly
in the sky I can go twice the size
a reading so he captures Jenna and holds
her on a room made out of tinfoil the
others break into the castle and try to
get her back my god the fabulous
baseball diamond
golly you're the most imagine we said
I've ever met
how long did it take you to plan on this
do you do potato so the where wizard
tries to attack Conan as his friend's
wife helplessly a Conan discovers he has
to destroy the mirrors in order to
destroy the whip which is a little
strange I mean if you're the wizard why
would you want your weakness surrounding
the room it's like Superman decorating
his Fortress of Solitude with kryptonite
curtains I don't need any meals I know I
trap it
boy he's taking that sword through his
chest pretty well isn't he I mean I
would scream or something but he keeps
all his pain inside and I respect that
wait a minute thanks for crashed through
the door the whole time why did they
just do that before weather just looking
for the doorbell to be polite so as the
journey continues we find that the niece
has quite the attraction of Conan and
she tries to see if she can get some
dating tips from midday here because she
really looks like a person who's into
girly talk I didn't know women could be
warriors who said I was a woman
all my tribe are warriors how do you
attract a man I spear him got him
then wear him what I mean is suppose you
set your heart on somebody take him and
take him like that I often use my club
to bash him on the head and drag him to
my cave by his hair but that's all
yesterday girlfriend but Jenna fine she
needs someone more sophisticated to talk
about sex with in order for a man to
really know a woman and and for her to
know him they have to uh to join join
yes the take is is a incredible by the
their York joint I mean how do you think
flowers grow the level of sexual inside
this guy has is just mind-blowing isn't
it hell I love to see this guy on some
sort of sex talk show oh you know with
that that the things and the guys over
here woman's over here and that and the
joining and that with the big and that
the you know flowers so they find Castle
number two and locate the treasure the
Queen was talking about but they're
greeted by some unpleasant company on
their way out we have to keep this alone
then you know what will happen if the
horn is placed back in the
ahead of data the God would live again
no one here with the control enough talk
look bloke I told him the crime stabber
so they fight their way through and hide
behind some sort of magic door a pubic
beard here it turns out is also a wizard
as he uses his powers to open the door
up 20 per minute did his magic just make
a dinging sound oh man he must have been
the laughingstock at Hogwarts don't you
think my magic produces my magic
produces my magic goes
luckily Maiko uses his own magic to show
the wizard the most frightening image he
can conjure up
so the captain gives our heroes the slip
as he writes off with Jenna where are
the others
yeah coming don't worry gopher hello can
you think that I'm an idiot
so they arrived at the castle as our
heroes are not far behind today is your
birthday all of shadows are is
celebrating drink tit dare I mean
killing you I mean life I mean killing
you that's the fearsome fire break into
the castle when they come across the
captain who plans to stop them from
boarding Jenna's sacrifice
so what's my birthday cue is it a pony
is it a dagger and a pony is it you
stabbing me in the photo you can
resurrect a god in order to control him
and hopefully rule the world and a pony
oh yeah I guess we have been standing
here the whole time
ah he was confused because I thought
there was an easily breakable piece of
glass in front of us see that's the only
thing they could hold us back so because
she's not sacrificed the statue is
instead transformed into hay but then
James Earl Jones snake scene just got
out silly it looks like one of those
wrecking bass stop-motion figures if it
was shit out by Swamp Thing but our
comic weasel it's nice enough to throw a
dagger into his ah boy I feel a little
weird saying this but Conan is literally
fighting a one-eyed 1-point giant purple
people eater and you know what it sure
looks strange to me so Conan kills the
creature as he delivers the final blow
if you can believe it weasel man here
actually tries to take credit for the
victory
Soula ah I need a captain of the guards
I see no reason why a woman wouldn't do
as well as a man you shall be called
punky brewster the brave the world's
greatest wizard come forward please
not you I said the world's greatest
wizard just kidding
one cannot rule without wisdom
rulz shutters are with me I need a royal
cherrypopper any more than qualified I
will have my own Kingdom my own Queen I
will own the beautiful land of
California California so Conan rides off
to find his own Kingdom and thus we get
an ending pretty much identical to the
first one its till at last he found his
own Kingdom and wore his crown upon a
troubled brow another story that I will
not tell because I am dead
Schwarzenegger's in California and this
franchise is non-existent so those are
the conan movies how do they measure up
well the second one is just crap once in
a while there's something interesting
but for the most part is just boring
the first one however I gotta admit it's
sort of a guilty pleasure for me I mean
again it's stupid but it's so perfectly
stupid the characters are memorable the
cinematography is great and the music is
some of the best I've ever heard him
it's kind of hard not to enjoy it not
granted I've never read the original
stories and from what I hear the movie
doesn't do them any justice but I still
like the first one for its corniness for
its grand scale and for its over-the-top
execution is it bad sure that's a very
enjoyable kind of man and if you're an
Arnold fan you'll definitely check it
out but how well conan matchup against
the armies of darkness Satan himself in
the end of days that is another story
I'm betting he wins
you